Speaking at a packed hall like Cairo University,...
...President Obama said after decades of frustration and distrust,...
...it is time for candor, for dialog and a fresh start.
I've come here to Cairo to seek a new beginning between the United States and Muslims around the world.
One based on mutual interest and mutual respect.
He said both sides need to reject stereotypes and speak the truth.
But I am convinced that in order to move forward,...
...we must say openly to each other the things we hold in our hearts...
...and that too often are said only behind closed doors.
There must be a sustained effort to listen to each other.
To learn from each other.
To respect one another.
And to seek common ground.
Mr. Obama said they must face their differences head-on...
...and forge a partnership to confront joint challenges.
From violent extremism, to Iran,...
...to the Arab-Israeli conflict.
Turning to the peace process, the president called for a dose of reality.
Using the term Palestine, he said the U.S. does not accept the legitimacy of Israeli settlements.
And that both sides must acknowledge the right of the other to exist.
But if we see this conflict only from one side or the other,...
...then we will be blind to the truth.
The only resolution is for the aspirations of both sides to be met through two states,...
...where Israelis and Palestinians each live in peace and security.